oh hi everybody welcome to another very
special episode of Game life has this
ever happened to you you you go to start
up playing your nintendo entertainment
system and the next thing you know it's
glitching out its screens flashing
colors you can't get to your game of
super mario brothers in duck hunt well
we are going to tell you right now right
here how to make your old NES system
work just like new the main problem with
the nes is a 72 pin connectors that the
game plugs into what over time we're out
and the pins would bend and just make
for a pretty bad connection after a
while yeah i mean you can actually you
know when i go to thrift stores i'll
find old nes systems that are that
people think it is broken for a couple
of bucks each and then you can go into
ebay and buy the 72 pin connectors for
what a couple of dollars each yeah i
think a dollar or two yes so you can
actually make a killing doing this and
it's really very easy doesn't require a
whole lot of technical skill right all
right so let's bust open this Nintendo
Entertainment System figure out what it
is we need to do to make it work like
brand new again alright so the first
step is to remove the top cover from the
nes now if you flip the Nintendo over
there's actually six screws around the
base that you need to remove to get the
top cover off
alright so now that the top cover is
removed the next thing that you need to
take off is the RF shield now this has
seven screws around the edges here so we
just need to pull all those out alright
and once the screws are removed the RF
field slides right off and next we have
to remove the screws that hold in the
game tray so before you can remove the
game trade and actually access the 72
pin connector you need to take out the
two screws on the corners of the RF unit
this will allow you to move the main
board
so now that the the main board can move
a little bit we can actually pick it up
and slide off the game track and now
here is the 72 pin connector now we're
going to be replacing so to remove this
from the board have to just simply slide
it towards the back of the system pops
right off and then we can just replace
the old connector with the new one and
now you just have to reassemble the
system and so now we've got our complete
brand new 72 pin connector installed in
our nes so what do you say let's get rid
of this broken one right here and see if
the brand-new one actually works sounds
good okay and a hush falls over the
crest yes Oh victory that's right this
just swapping out the 72 pin connector
which you can buy for a dollar and
that's all you need to do to make your
nes work just like new once again I just
want to give a big game life thank you
to our studio audience for helping us
out today is doing awesome now remember
you can make your nes work like new2
with a Phillips head screwdriver a 72
pin connector that you can buy off of
ebay and a brother who will do a video
for free
you